welcome to CBS this morning we're going
to begin again with the terrible brutal
weather and brutal is a word an arctic
blast is slamming the u.s. and is
expected to bring dangerously cold
conditions to more than half of the
country
winter weather alerts are in effect
across more than a dozen states more
than 220 million Americans that's a lot
of people will experience below freezing
temperatures in the next 24 to 48 hours
though is hammering States from the
Midwest to New England making for
treacherous travel conditions our lead
national correspondent David Beck know
is in Pittsford New York that's just
outside Rochester so David good morning
how cold is it there good morning it's a
balmy 23 degrees as we stand here along
the Erie Canal hello good morning cute
puppies there it looks like a winter
wonderland in the fall listen you're
probably thinking how did a guy from the
south get sent up north to cover the
snow that's what happens this time of
year and that's fair
but it doesn't always happen this early
and the big story is the record-setting
temperatures from north to south you
gotta expect a little snow in November
but this is a little early for me just
ask people in Dowagiac Michigan they
were not expecting weather like this
near whiteout snow as much as five
inches were forecast to come down
overnight if you pick it up like this
it's very light and fluffy
flurries fell as far south as Nashville
Tennessee where some people were happy
to get an early glimpse of winter in the
village of Alden New York population
10,000 we noticed brothers Gavin and
grant outside playing in the snow what
do y'all think of the snow pretty good
huh
but the conditions also led to numerous
crashes on Monday from New York to
Missouri to Illinois where in Chicago an
icy runway at O'Hare Airport sent this
American Airlines plane skidding into
the grass
morning the weather also stops some
travelers from flying all together
Cleveland resident Tammy Pepin bus was
trying to get to Florida definitely
disappointed I was supposed to be in
West Palm Beach by 10:30 tonight her
flight was one of nearly 6000 nationwide
that was delayed yesterday not to
mention the more than 1,800
cancellations and with more
record-setting weather expected today
air traffic may not be much better you
know there'll be more delays today look
when it comes to record-setting
temperatures they expect that a hundred
and forty five Records will be broken by
the end of the day and winter doesn't
even start until December 21st happy
fall keep moving out there neighbors are
set to plummet over the next 24 hours
ahead of a deep freeze expected to
shatter records as David said chief
weather caster Lonnie Quinn of our New
York station wcbs-tv is here Lonnie how
long is this gonna last well we may get
a little bump in temperatures you know
come Thursday but I like your your your
your response to David happy fall it
doesn't feel like fall outside for a lot
of folks but some folks this morning it
feels like fall by this evening it's not
going to and I'm talking to East Coast
here's our front moving across the
country ket biggest snows will be
upstate New York and the Vermont could
see upwards of a foot but look at Texas
the radar is serving up every color we
have to offer in Texas Corpus Christi
degree in its range San Antonio San
Antonio the pink it's sleet south of
Austin that purple color that's freezing
rain north of Austin there's snow so the
area north of Austin will see their
first snowflakes before New York City
it's rain right now for New York and
from New York to Boston
you're gonna transition to some snow
it's gonna be a little bit just a little
bit tenths of an inch of snow the
temperatures will be a big story right
now the coldest air anywhere from I'll
say Fargo over to Chicago seven below
zero nine below zero is what it feels
like right now look at the East Coast
you're walking out the door it feels
right now like 50 degrees in Boston
51 Philadelphia 53 in Charlotte that's
walking out the door coming home from
work tonight you sure as heck had better
take the winter coat because it feels
like 21 in Boston 27 for Philadelphia it
feels like 33 in Charlotte and when you
look at the big picture as far as the
entire United States by Wednesday
six o'clock in the morning every state
in our country will have at least some
place that feels sub-freezing every
state in the United States
nowhere to hide Lonnie thank you very
much and of course I did forget my
winter coat today but I'll survive I got
one upstairs old engine appreciate it
it's lodged are a lining we